[Applause]
[Music]
hey you're back
and that's a good thing what I need you
to do is like follow and subscribe head
ILP and then hit the little bell icon of
this so you can be notified when new
compact talk comes up or when new flash
points come out or when new ILP
information runs that way you can be
notified but in order to get all the
great stuff that we have for you guys
you must hit the like button and you
must subscribe see some Maisie boxing
gym
you go all the main street fighters come
from 100% as you can see there's a lot
of bags full size ring for your limping
training a lot of champions came in and
out of this place come here and train
young and old every bag imaginable speed
bag heavy bag full body bag full size
ring trying bad talk with the Kings now
the fight happened then you call me a
defeated Louis Louis I mean let's let's
let's not even try to say we thought
that Derek really had a chance I'm going
to go into that whole thing he defeat
him in the second round and read really
naked show aha shout out to Lord kognito
bare naked choke yeah say inside joke
Yop guys if you follow like follow
subscribe make sure that you watching
IOP a podcast on Sundays it's ridiculous
um ok so let's get to the crust of the
whole fight and why this fight actually
happened
Derek lose made enough noise to be seen
and he generated ticket sales ticket
sales got him to the big show was he
ready for the big show no Daniel Cormier
took the fight on short notice because
Daniel Cormier knew that Derrick Lewis
was not in his League alright and in
insane that I'm not discrediting Derrick
Lewis work ethic it's just the fact that
Derrick Lewis is too green to be a guy
like Darren you call me you have to be
an exceptional talent because Daniel
Cormier he's not flashy he's not um he's
a great champion is he a special
champion and there's a difference I mean
let me give you the difference the
difference between a special champion
and a great champion a special champion
is the champion who has everything he
has the charisma that pizzazz that flash
that Journal said qua that that
unquantifiable thing that substance that
you see it and you automatically know
Oscar De La Hoya had it you knew for
Mayweather has it you knew Sugar Ray
Leonard has it you know it's it's it's a
difference John Wong Jobs has that then
you call me he doesn't have that now is
that taken away from him being a great
champion no see what Daniel Cormier has
is a complete worth ethic his
fundamentals is sound he practices it
over and over and over again because
somebody told him at some point in time
in his life you must be more prepared
and if you put in the work you will
achieve your goals and then you core me
he puts in that work Daniel Cormier is
in that gym then you Kwame is hitting
that weights Daniel Cormier is on that
mat wrestling pushing itself now the
difference between a great fighter and a
special fighter as a special fighter can
maybe take off here in there cut a
little corners a lot right or Roy Jones
and still beat a great fighter
a great fighter can't take a deal a
great fighter must always put in that
work all right Bernard Hopkins he's a
great fighter and she flash makes
special fight I know he's not he's a
great fighter but back to Derrick Lewis
it saddens me because you know watching
a fight you knew from round one
when Daniel Cormier grabbed him and took
him down easily by one leg takedown come
on man it was it was absolutely no
effort Derrick Lewis had no defense for
the takedown
absolutely zero we all knew going into
this fight Derrick Lewis only had one
shot at it and that was uh if he catches
the core mate coming in off he if he he
jumps on Cormier right somebody in his
training camp one of his trainers
thought it was a great idea for him to
let Cormier make a mistake then you
capitalize think jump you idiot your
only shot is to go and take him out and
you will earn your back foot that coach
instead of protecting the commodity you
give your guy the greatest fighting
chance that he has to win if you truly
believe in you got I don't believe
anybody I actually believe that Derrick
loss is not win that fight now I don't
believe anybody I don't even believe
Derrick Lewis thought he was gonna win
that fight because he is it's a
difference this is difference walking
around saying that you're the man and
believing you're the man amongst men so
Derrick Lewis was supposed to go into
the fight
and jump all all over Cormier I don't
care what it looked like I don't care if
you ran out of energy after three
minutes I don't care if we had a minute
worth energy in your body you weren't
going to beat him anyway so why not go
out on your shield swinging why not give
that crowd the greatest Derrick Lewis
had to offer
what I saw was someone who knew he was a
lamb led to the slaughter someone who
knew that it was just a matter of time
it was a guy with a brick above his head
and he was afraid to move see to be
great you have to dare to be great only
a special talent will beat Daniel
Cormier only a special talent can defeat
him like John bones John has but it's
about the fight game getting paid off
all the blood sweat and tears over
fighters who were already a fighters
that [ __ ] have been in the ring actually
to fight at all
so I must say was I disappointed no the
fight lived up exactly to my
expectations I knew for a fact that
Daniel Cormier was gonna do it by
carrying a fight into the second round
and for me it could have ended the fight
in the first round but taking the fight
to the second round and showing allowing
Shawn respect to Derrick Lewis allowing
him to you know flash some of his shots
you know give the crowd their money's
worth all you guys should take your hat
off the Daniel Cormier
for being a true champion and for being
a gentleman he is exactly who he needs
to be double champion every weight light
heavyweight it may not be exactly who
you want but he is exactly who he is
double champion Daniel Cormier and
technically if you quickly look at it
you mix undefeated there's a lot of
things is in question with the other guy
to beat him this is combat talk with the
king hopefully next time we can get call
me into a real dust up a real good fight
somebody can actually test his skills so
you can actually see the best to call me
[Applause]
[Music]